speaking of bad stuff to put in your
body
Cracker Barrel
it no Cracker Barrel's not the bad stuff
I love Cracker Barrel the bad stuff to
put in your body in this context
is the fake sausage that Cracker Barrel
is is now peddling
Cracker Barrel had this post it went up
yesterday they said discover new meat
Frontiers experience the Out of This
World flavor of the impossible sausage
made from plants next time you build
your own breakfast the story was brought
to my attention by Aaron McIntyre
I I looked at this story I thought oh my
gosh this is
this is the most devastating argument
against the free market I've ever heard
in my life
this is devastating because there is no
way in hell that the vegan vegetarian
whatever fake sausage at Cracker Barrel
is being driven by customer demand not
one single person who has ever walked
into a Cracker Barrel would even
consider eating fake vegetarian sausage
not one
people who walk into Cracker Barrel
myself included tend to be a little
heartier a little more old school
sometimes a little more on the Big Bubba
side of things what they would want if
there were going to be any change to
Cracker Barrel sausage they would want
them to add more meat to it they would
want the sausage to be pork and beef and
probably veal and they would just add as
much meat as possible okay this decision
is being driven
from the top
this decision is woke Executives or who
knows the kinds of people in in
fun in the big funding firms you know
and whatever it is venture capital and
the public markets we're pushing ESG
environmental social governance policies
they're the kind of people who are
saying we need to impose these new
standards the same people who want us to
live in our pods and eat the bugs and
not own anything and be totally happy
and stop driving cars and take bicycles
everywhere and take public
transportation these are the people who
say Don't eat you don't get to eat your
sausage anymore you don't get to eat
meat now you have to eat impossible meat
yum yum it's so delicious that's where
those decisions are coming from this is
not a corporation responding to market
demand
and unfortunately that's that's the way
that a lot of our
our Market operates that's the way a lot
of our businesses operate this is why
though I'm a conservative and I have a
ton of respect for free markets and I
think free markets can be a good means
to an end for a flourishing Society I do
not worship at the altar of the free
market okay
because I I know one that free markets
can be so easily perverted and two it
takes a political order to set the
parameters of a market just like you
think of a physical Marketplace that you
go to a physical Marketplace has little
roads and streets and building codes and
and ways that it's designed and that's
that is established by the political
order well the same thing holds true in
the economic market and the more
abstract market and the fact is there
are a lot of activists out there who are
manipulating Market forces to try to not
respond to customer demand but to change
customer demand and to turn us into a
nation of to use a popular phrase weak
soy boy beta cucks who are just we're
just eating a bunch of fake plant
sausage instead of good delicious pork
sausage like we were intended to eat so
I I certainly will never eat the
impossible sausage or Cracker Barrel
I've seen outrage from fellow Cracker
Barrel fans like I am and if those guys
know what's good for them they will get
rid of this vegetarian crap from the
menu because until they do
I am not stepping foot back into a
Cracker Barrel these woke Executives
think they can force their will on us I
don't think so Buster hit him where it
hurts right in the pocketbook right now
head on over to puretalk.com enter promo
code Knowles bite inflation has left
every business trying to nickel and dime
you they're all trying to figure out how
much they can squeeze you to offset
their increasing costs not pure talk
that's why I love Pure Talk Pure Talk
drew the Line in the Sand they said stop
screwing over the American public when
you sign up with pure talk this month
you are going to get their best offer
yet you are going to get one month
free just completely free you're going
to save probably two-thirds of what
you're you're currently spending on your
cell phone bill for all the talk all the
text all the data you want on America's
most reliable 5G Network you're going to
do all of that for 30 bucks a month
except for that first month where it's
zero dollars a month right now when you
make that switch go to puretalk.com
enter promo code Knowles for this
special offer do you need another reason
when you choose pure talk you're
choosing to support American jobs not a
company that sends them overseas to
China or other places that hate us
you're choosing to support a
veteran-owned american-based company and
most important of all a sponsor of
everything we do here at the daily wire
and the sponsor of the voicemail bag
which is my favorite segment so head on
over right now to puretalk.com select a
plan maybe add a new iPhone or Android
whatever you want add promo code Knowles
k-o-w-l-e-s get one month for free hi
Michael thank you for listening to my
question
um so with all of the Beyonce
controversy going on I thought now would
be a good time to bring up her music
video and I believe this is back from
2008. it's called XO and at the three
minute and six second Mark there's a
flash of an actual demon and it has
nothing to do with the song or the video
it's very scary and it's barely a second
long
I haven't heard anybody talk about it
and I don't understand why the word spaz
is so controversial but an actual demon
that does not belong there why is nobody
talking about it and also on her
lemonade album
there's like a poem that she did and
there's a line in it that says I plugged
my Menses with pages from the holy book
so that sounds like witchcraft to me
I've also heard that she has lawsuits
due to severe witchcraft like her tour
mates or whatever said that she was like
using their kittens as sacrifices and
it's very scary so I just wanted another
pair of eyes on this to maybe shine some
Spotlight on it and see what the heck is
going on with Beyonce so thank you again
for taking my question and have a
blessed day
so I don't know about the the Witchcraft
kitten stuff but I do remember the demon
image and it's really really weird if
you haven't seen this video it just
Beyonce just flashes a demon like an
actual demon just without any
any reason that that would come from the
plot of the music video or anything like
it just flashes the demon there and I
have to tell you I'm not surprised when
that sort of stuff happens because the
devil is the prince of this world
because we're fighting against a
principalities and powers and spiritual
wickedness in the high places so when
when that
peeks through the the veil a little bit
I'm not I'm not really all that
surprised
uh
demons are real the devil is real to
quote Anthony Scalia when he was giving
an interview to every glib New York
Magazine reporter
many more intelligent people than you
and me have believed in the devil okay
uh you you should have a healthy
caution about
spiritual wickedness you you should you
should have a healthy fear of sin and do
your best not to sin because it's all
real okay it is all real C.S Lewis makes
an important Point too which is
sometimes when people come to realize
that good and bad are are real things
and the Devil is a real person and uh
people get really really interested in
that in the occult in and you're you are
seeing a rise in interest in the occult
right now
especially as public Christianity wanes
and
C.S Lewis gives good advice which is
you should not
you should not totally ignore the fact
that demons are real
you you need to be aware of it but you
shouldn't be too interested either
be aware of it know that it's real be on
guard
you know that the devil is crouching in
the corner sin is crouching in the
corner waiting to pounce on you and
Gobble you up at every given second we
are living in a world of intense
spiritual combat happening all around us
and through us uh
but don't harp on it all the time okay I
don't know what Beyonce is doing I mean
she's had all sorts of weird
uh occult kind of imagery in her music
for a long time so I hope you know hope
things turn out okay for her uh but when
as far as it pertains to you I don't
really care about Beyonce all that much
though we do share a last name and are
probably cousins uh you know as it
pertains to you I wouldn't focus on it
too much uh just do the right thing and
don't sin don't sin and don't sacrifice
any cats and don't do whatever
Beyonce allegedly did with the book and
all you know with the Bible and every
don't do that and just you know just
okay do the right thing so glad you like
that clip now hold up wait don't go look
I know I got a million subscribers here
on YouTube that's great I'm thrilled I'm
very grateful to all of you who took us
to that level now I want to reach one
trillion I know it's a little bit of a
lofty goal I want to do it I think we
can you've got to subscribe ring the
bell get the notifications we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
thank you